i also want to put it into perspective
that i just read like
three and a half hours of porn before
this so reading this
last was not a good way to end my day i
was already quite done with reading porn
and then you have to bear in mind there
was probably no way i was going to find
any if it was the whole that's what you
get for doing your homework the day
before it starts i was given the thing
the day before i was given this two days
ago
so you know i think that also didn't
help because there was no way i was ever
going to find any of these things
attractive because i was pretty much
my you know i was pretty dumb yeah yeah
with reading porn you've read one yeah
yeah yeah i've read so much
quarter of reading i literally read like
what i think is like a normal person's
like
month worth of porn yeah yeah you know
so i was pretty exhausted
the fact that this came up and i just
saw the right through it right away i
knew exactly what they were going to do
right from the start i was just like you
know
it's fine you know i see what you're
trying to do you're trying to be sad
yeah
and i don't appreciate it frankly
you know the whole like at the moment
that her dad looked at her i'm like i
see what you're doing here buddy
your next line is i i i actually we keep
talking about the dad but i think that
dad
is the worst part of the dojin because
it was just like
for me reading the dad episode was just
like let's just throw let's
see literally i would rather eat my own
toenails yeah and read them again
but like like what like what like it was
after the dad dojin
that the dad chapter part when i'm just
like yo this is
this is really engrossing as a story
right
i knew it was going there the moment he
gave her a drug i'm like
he's literally going to sell her later
on and use drugs for yeah
it was so obvious it was going there and
so when it went there i was like i was
not even surprised
the dad thing caught me off guard i had
a feeling it might happen and then when
it did happen i'm like for [ __ ]
sake yeah god damn it
god damn it because because like to me
it was just like
it was just it was just the feeling of
just being like this is the most
depraved [ __ ]
i shouldn't feel horny at all this
situation is
just people jacking off to this i don't
think so i don't know probably something
i mean
because the thing is the thing is it was
it was it was that emotion
juxtaposed between how amazing the sex
scenes were cause like
out of context extra doubt on this no
out of context
out of context no i don't think the sex
the art the art was [ __ ] amazing
was a [ __ ] ugly bastard so how much
was to get behind that [ __ ]
i mean it wasn't all ugly it wasn't all
it was
okay so it was we had two very big
scenes
with older men yeah and it was very
gross because
there were six chapters and two maybe
three of them were ugly bosses and
which frankly one is too many
i mean the fact that i read this [ __ ]
and i thought it's bad enough she's
[ __ ] some random dude for money
who is literally the ugliest man on
earth yeah and then next it's like
it's like [ __ ] smash bros introducing
a new fighter
a [ __ ] dad into this [ __ ] up story
already which is already pressing as
[ __ ] because
everyone in the [ __ ] school has had a
go at her yeah it's just like that
that [ __ ] alone i was like you know what
like i i sh yeah sure
japanese kids are [ __ ] up but like
this is too much this is
this would never happen no way in any
school would this ever happen
well it's interesting because like i
interviewed shinderwell
like a couple of years ago yeah and we
talked about this i was like because i
wanted to know i was like
what you know inspired metamorphosis um
and he said that
he because he was born and raised in new
york yeah so he was like
i heard and saw so many stories
that were similar to this right and he
was like i wanted to bring light to it
because
otherwise no one [ __ ] talks about it
i bet this [ __ ]
has happened like separately
yeah like all of these individual things
no no absolutely definitely yeah yeah
yeah but this isn't based off of really
i know i know but the fact that like you
string these all together to a point
where i'm just like i suspend my
disbelief and i'm like yeah
no it's not supposed to be realistic but
it's supposed to be
it's basically i think it in my opinion
it was shindo all being like
look this [ __ ] happens but like i think
about movies that [ __ ] me up and i think
that could be me i could make that
mistake i could be in that situation
in this one i was like this is well yeah
because you're not a chick
even then like i feel like it was it was
trying too hard well that's fine
i i think the most fantastical element
was it of it
was how much he enjoyed the sex right
because because
because that was that was i i feel that
was the big difference between
that was also an uncomfortable part i'm
like is this is this good is it what she
wants
i don't know that's the one that's
that's the most interesting
thing that that to me is what like drew
me in was like was was like the fact
that she
enjoyed the sex so much which i know
it's like without resource music
no no no that's that's the point right
where it's just like it's
such a like a mess of emotions that it's
just like you don't you have no
grounding
it questions your morality the entire
time there's
like no grounding on this kind of
situation because
personally i don't know anyone who's
[ __ ] their dads
and i want to push more people and i
kind of i want
i kind of want to keep it that way you
know like that's that's just me i don't
know if that's a hot take but like i
just i just
i hope that i hope that that never
happens to any [ __ ] body yeah
but i mean yeah that's the point it's
[ __ ] it's it's it's fiction right yeah
but
like the the thing that drew me in was
that it was just these [ __ ] up
situations juxtaposed between
sex scenes that she obviously really
enjoyed at the time
right and i'm just like yo this is like
really
weird this is like a weird car crash of
different [ __ ] things i shouldn't be
feeling right now but i'm just like
i don't know how to like i'm still like
processing it now right because it's
like the only time
the reason i call it the reason i call
this a masterpiece is that
it's the only time i felt this emotion
that i'm trying to describe
right now right normally normally you
get depressed
normally you get horny you don't talk
about depression depression boner do you
like like that that just doesn't happen
right but metamorphosis is just these
two [ __ ] things that shouldn't
coexist together
together together
and that's why i think it's brilliant as
well it's because he took such a [ __ ]
risk with this
where he was like this could have easily
just been like a weird thing
that no one would have picked up and
just like brushed under all of the oh
okay that's [ __ ] weird let's not talk
about that
pile of dojins that are out there but
there was just again he just presented
it in a way
where it was just like you came for the
horny
but you're gonna stay for the depression
whether you like it or not yeah
and like i don't know any other dojin
that's managed to do that and
managed to make me stay the entire time
until the end
you've seen uh the shia labeouf movie
nymphomaniac
no no i haven't that's like the three
hour long one right it's like there's
two parts to it yeah yeah
yeah yeah i felt like that was a really
uncomfortable depiction of a woman who's
addicted to sex
right i felt like that was really
somewhat well done i thought that's an
interesting movie
it's a very hard watch yeah really it's
very long yeah yeah
it's very uncomfortable because it's
like it's that that [ __ ] like uh
really avant-garde direction yeah it is
and it's one of those things where it's
like
it really reminds you like you think
you're cool with sex until you see it in
really uncomfortable ways and you're
like yeah
yeah that's the last one true movie i
kind of have weird
thoughts about because it really makes
you be like oh you're comfortable sex
bet yeah yeah like and i feel like
you know having experienced that kind of
weird [ __ ] i feel like going into this
i'm like yeah i can kind of buy why
she's into it but also
i feel like it's been done better in
different places almost
i'm not saying that movie did it better
essentially but i feel like
i've seen it done in a way where i'm
like i think this is done slightly more
realistic to the point where i'm like i
believe it i believe it
yeah right but it's hard to like i get
it how like you know movies like
nephromaniac
probably did this whole thing better
yeah but at the same time neither maniac
has
the upside of being more realistic by
using real actors that's true i mean
we shouldn't like the biggest thing
because it's hard to for me personally
to who's never read doujins to see this
and be like damn that's [ __ ] that's
art man that's
yeah i mean i like i i
we literally just chucked you in the
deep end and just like like tried to see
i mean you know it's it's like i i'm not
used to this genre
yeah you know this i mean i don't think
anyone is there's all these kind of
tropes in here
and then there's this girl i'm just to
believe is this kind of well done
character and i'm like yeah i don't
believe it man personally at least
i mean possibly at least you can now say
you read men
i've read it i'm not proud of that fact
i want to undo the reading that i've
done
so what what would you give it out of 10
in terms of what
in terms of just like like how you felt
about it four
four it's an interesting read and what
would you give it ten
hell yeah hell yeah
what does sydney think of it um i don't
know what sydney thinks about you should
ask
and frankly i'm afraid to ask because i
should be like it's the hardest [ __ ]
i have heard too many things that have
worried me in my past
the past few months of my relationship
that i'm kind of afraid to ask her
opinion of like any hentai right now
so i guess i'll leave it at that then
huh
jesus